can predisode affect tumor markers? I don't know I haven't seen any data that
predisode will change tumor markers but I just doubt if there's ever been a
study on it so I don't know I don't know so tumor markers are essentially
different enzymes that your body cells give off. Not just cancer cells you notice if we've
ever had done tumor markers that there's a normal range but the normal range is there because
it's normal in your body to have those markers too and we call them tumor markers but in reality
there are just enzymes that your body makes. Cancer cells tend to make some cancer cells
tend to make access numbers of those enzymes and then you can use them as a marker or tumors
hence the name tumor markers and they're considered in a classification of different tumor markers
but they're actually normal enzymes which your body makes. Predisode is anti-inflammatory
affects the cytokines possibly I don't know if I cannot the mad try to think of the physiology
I don't know that they will maybe there's some weird physiological process that we cause
tumor markers to call out that I don't think so